I feel like man versus food right now
this is the point where like it hits you
and and you feel like you're gonna die
Hey
I have never been in a food competition
before I've never participated in any
food eating competition before in fifth
grade I was third in a Twinkie eating
contest in my elementary school I'm done
like the Buffalo Wild Wings hot wing
challenge I've eaten the monster burrito
Freebirds like that's technically a
competition y'all you're gonna see me
throw up or pass out either way it's not
gonna end well for me there are three of
us the reverse one like we there has to
be some sort of odds in our favor
I am yesterday and I'm a competitive
eater a marathoner and a triathlete
I set the world record in
corn-on-the-cob in 2016 with 47
corn-on-the-cob in 12 minutes I've also
set the record for cannoli I believe was
30 somewhat in 6 minutes and I also hold
multiple records and the Tour de donut
bicycle aces and my record there is 61
Donuts over the course of a 29 mile race
the challenge here for the other team is
they're gonna have to move pretty
quickly through the food it might not be
a ton of food for each person but I can
take down that amount of food when much
quicker than they can
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
three two Apollo one Thanksgiving
[Music]
[Music]
why is there's more food a building
keeps appearing I believe I could
possibly throw up not going to but in
the future may throw up
you laughing you're making you laugh Oh
Oh what was thought medically I feel
like I should not eat any more food I
don't need to I'm getting turkey gravy
mashed potatoes corn stuffing by like
three minutes I don't want to do are you
popping out we're not tapping out okay
we're discussing but we haven't tapped
out yet there's not much more room here
at the medical professionals should I
stop I feel like I'm either gonna [ __ ]
my pants I'm gonna throw up I proved
enough to myself I'm tap it out I don't
know what we proved or what we did but
we've got pretty close to doing things
with our mouths now you're gonna see me
throw up or pass out either way it's not
gonna end well for me
the other team did a lot better than I
thought but they tapped out and I
encouraged them next time let's do this
again I honestly wasn't very confident
going in and as soon as I put that
turkey in my mouth that first bite I
knew it was not going to go well food
for five people three people actually we
can do that and then I saw the food and
I was like we know all things aside it's
always cool to see how far the human
body can go I feel like we test our
limits today yeah we didn't hold back we
bonded and now just make me appreciate
this giving that much more knowing I
don't have to eat it in three minutes
with three pounds of food and gravy
[Music]